vamos a continuar resolviendo este
problema aquí dice un poco es no cómico
si la resistencia cambia en función de
la corriente tu configuración del inciso
a que tenemos aquí sea usará o
modificará para determinar si el foco
económico como debería modificarse la
configuración si es que fuera necesario
bueno queremos poder cambiar la
corriente que pasa por el foco para
luego ver si cambia la resistencia con
la configuración que tenemos aquí es muy
fácil medir la resistencia
sabemos que el voltaje es igual a la
corriente por la resistencia o que la
resistencia es igual al voltaje entre la
corriente así que si conocemos la
corriente que pasa por el foco y
conocemos el voltaje a través de éste
podremos encontrar su resistencia por lo
que esta configuración que tenemos es
muy buena para encontrar la resistencia
del foco entonces necesitamos cambiar la
corriente para ver cómo cambia la
resistencia hay un par de maneras en las
que podemos cambiar la corriente podemos
cambiar la resistencia aquí pero
afortunadamente aquí tenemos una fuente
de poder variable por lo que podemos
cambiar el voltaje que pasa por todo el
circuito y si cambiamos el voltaje que
pasa por todo el circuito también
cambiaremos la corriente que pasa por
este circuito que tiene todos sus
elementos en serie así que si cambiamos
la corriente en todo el circuito
cambiaremos la corriente que pasa por el
foco y solo tendremos que medir de eeuu
para saber si cambia r también así que
necesita modificarse la configuración
del inciso a no necesita modificarse
en la siguiente sección nos preguntan
qué información adicional tendría que
recabar sé si fuera necesario vamos a
escribir aquí abajo la sección se la
parte 1 de la parte se es
necesita
modificarse
puedo
cambiar
corriente
ajustando
ajustando la fuente
de poder
y puedo medir la resistencia del foco
medir la resistencia del foco
voltaje
a través del foco a través
del foco
/ corriente que está entrando o saliendo
y sé que en la primera parte del texto
nos preguntan si tenemos el mismo número
de electrones por segundo que entran y
salen del foco pero por lo que sabemos
de la corriente esta va a ser la misma
en cualquier lado del foco si tenemos
una caída de voltaje entonces nuestra
corriente va a ser la misma así que la
corriente que entra y sale es la misma y
aún cuando ustedes no supieran lo que
les acabo de decir la primera parte del
experimento se los habría indicado la
corriente que entra o sale del foco es
la misma así que esto de aquí es igual a
r la resistencia del foco puedo cambiar
la corriente al ajustar la fuente de
poder y puedo calcular la resistencia al
medir estas dos cosas conforme agua el
ajuste de la fuente de poder con esta
configuración segundo inciso que otra
información debería recabar sé
ok en esto necesito medir
el voltaje medir el voltaje
a través del foco
a través del foco conforme a justo
conforme ajusto la fuente de poder
la fuente de poder y también necesito
medir
la corriente
que entra o sale del foco
conforme a justo conforme ajusto la
fuente de poder tengo que medir ambas
cosas para poder calcular la resistencia
del foco y ahora veamos el inciso de
como analizaremos la información para
determinar si el foco es no o mikko
incluye una discusión sobre cómo las
incertidumbres en el voltímetro y en el
amperímetro puede afectar tu argumento
para concluir si el registro es no mico
bueno ya lo explique brevemente pero no
escribiré de nuevo inciso de lo que yo
haría es ajustar la fuente de poder
ajustar
fuente de poder
al primer voltaje al primer voltaje y
medir lo indicado arriba
y medir lo indicado arriba
usar esto
calcular
resistencia
del foco
usar esto para calcular la resistencia
del foco ajustar la fuente de poder
ajustar la fuente de poder al segundo
voltaje
al segundo voltaje y medir lo indicado
arriba
a lo indicado arriba
a ver si cambia la resistencia
si cambia la resistencia
ok si ve uno que es el primer voltaje a
través del foco entre y uno que es la
primera corriente que pasa por el foco
si esto es igual a de 2 entre y 2 que
son el voltaje y la corriente después de
que ajuste la fuente de poder entonces
vemos que no cómico es cuando la
resistencia cambia así que esto no será
no cómico no es no cómico de otra manera
si ve uno entre y uno es diferente de de
dos entre y dos entonces
no cómico
es no mico y debemos tener cuidado
porque la sensibilidad de nuestros
instrumentos pueden darnos resultados
erróneos por ejemplo nuestro foco podría
ser no mico pero dependiendo de cómo el
voltímetro o el amperímetro redondeen
sus mediciones podría darnos un cambio
en esto especialmente porque nuestro
amperímetro es más sensible aquí y por
otro lado podríamos tener una situación
en la que la resistencia no es no o mika
pero los instrumentos no registran
cambios porque estos cambios no son lo
suficientemente grandes para ser
registrados por el amperímetro y el
voltímetro debido a su sensibilidad
así que escribimos cuidar
sensibilidad cuidar la sensibilidad
los
instrumentos de los instrumentos
redondeo entre comillas a la décima de
volt más cercano oa la centésima de
amper
más cercano podría resultar en
diferencias
/ y cuando no las hay cuando no las hay
o viceversa
cuando hay diferencia pero no es lo
suficientemente grande para ser
registrada siempre debemos ser
cuidadosos en cualquier experimento de
cualquier ciencia de conocer la
sensibilidad de nuestros instrumentos y
qué redondeos hacen o podemos hacer para
nuestros cálculos